LENNIE MARTINEZ:
I'm Lennie Martinez.
I'm a sophomore in
AeroAstro, actually.
I'm part of the Saving
Gora Gora group.
Our game is called
Saving Gora Gora.
It's a game about-- well it has
to do with tropical cholera.
And our goal was
to teach children
how to prevent cholera, because
our target audience were
Gonian children ages 8
to 13, approximately.
And pretty much our
main goal was just
to educate them in a
fun way that wouldn't
seem like we're educating them.
Oh, OK.
So our design brief
was pretty general.
It said, look at the cholera
tool kit that's online,
that you find online,
and try to create a game
to teach kids about cholera.
So they gave us our
target audience,
which was Gonian
children ages 8 to 13.
And we we're thinking,
originally-- well, it
was an idea that we had based
off Animal Crossing, where
it's a bunch of
different mini games.
So each mini game would
include a small lesson.
And then, they would
all come together
to become one large MEDI PUZZLE.
And in solving the MEDI
PUZZLE, the players
would learn how to, I guess,
prevent cholera or counter
cholera, and that was what led
most of our design process.
The visual style came about-
well, we had a very-- well,
we had an original
visual silo that
was very different from what you
guys saw in the presentation.
We had to research-- we had
done research on children,
but we had to take a look
back and redo everything
because it wasn't as--
once we compared it,
once we had a finished
build, we compared it
to-- we had to do research
on what cartoons would better
look like.
And we found that it was very
different and very clashing.
So we did some research
some more on Gonian culture,
and we tried to find,
make it fit better.
And so we went for
more artsy, woodsy,
cartoonish little
people, very little kid,
but it's still not too
childish for other people.
I originally, really, was
interested in the class
because one of the textbooks
was Design of Everyday Things.
It's a book I find
really interesting.
I've been trying to
read it, but it's
hard with the curriculum,
the overall MIT curriculum.
So, I really came into
the class thinking
that I really wanted to work
on the design aspect of things.
But as we started
working on projects,
the match win side became a bit
more interesting, a bit more,
something I started working
a bit more because it was
more accessible for
me with my not so
robust knowledge of coding.
But then, later on for
this project particular,
I took the role of the writer.
So I was in charge of
writing most of the dialogue,
and that was also
very interesting.
So I feel like I gained
a lot more skills
than I thought I would have.
I think a really big
part of the process
is to start writing
really early.
The writing, we
left it off a bit
until we had the
general mini games
and used the writing to tie
everything back together.
But I think it would have been
a much more smoother process
or a much more
interesting process
if we had started the writing,
had we used the writing
to lead the design process.
But it wasn't, I
mean, it would have
been better had
we started early,
but it wasn't too bad or
too much of a difference
between the work we have now
and the work we had before.
But aside from that, I
think it's really important
to start and meet
early and sort of come
to a consensus on
what you want to do.
We had a lot of
mini-- the reason we--
we had a lot more mini games to
begin with than when we ended,
and it was good that we met
early and decided what to cut
and what to include.
And that helped us work
towards one common path.
Working with the client
was very interesting.
We met him two, three, four, or
five maybe, almost five times,
I think it was.
We've met him a
lot and interacting
with him was interesting.
The first time we
met him was where
he did a lot of demonstrations
was, sort of, I guess,
showed us more what we were
supposed to be aiming for,
because it was a very
social interaction,
very deep interaction.
And that I think the goal of
our games is to be a bit more,
is to be really deep
while also appearing
to be very just playful.
And he also helped us when we
were going on our art reworks,
that he was suggesting, like,
maybe you should look at these.
You should look more
at towards this type
of the culture, this part
of the culture or this part.
And that was very nice.
That's the sort of interacting.
The class has been
actually really fun.
It's a lot of work.
But it's a lot of
interesting work,
because once you see
the game-- I actually
hadn't seen the final
builds we had until today,
and it was like, this
actually is really--
I had written the dialogue
separately, so I was just
looking at the art assets.
And it was very nice to see
everything come together
in one nice build of, here's
the game you helped make.